[موسيقى]
شخص موسوعي عالمي ناجح جميل جدا ببساطته
وتواضعه صاحب الوجه المبتسم والعاشق دائما
للمزيد من البحث والتعلم دون تعب او ملل
الدكتور فاروق الباز مدير مركز الاستشعار
عن بعد في جامعه بوسطن هو شخصيه الاسبوع
في مساء العربيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يطلق عليك دكتور الكينج المصري يعني كنت
ضمن فريق ناسا لاستكشاف القمر حدثنا اكثر
عن القمر عن الثروات الموجوده في القمر
وابرز المعادن اكتشفت فيه اهم حاجه
عرفناها من رحلات للقمر بالنتيجه للعينات
اللي اخذها الرواد ان الارض والقمر تكونا
من نفس العناصر الكيميائيه وتقريبا في نفس
الوقت من الزمن يعني هم الاثنين
يعني اخوات
وتكونوا من نفس المواد فدي كانت مهمه جدا
ان احنا نعرف دي ان القمر مجامل مكان اخر
لا ده جاي من نفس المكان اللي احنا جايين
منه في المجموعه الشمسيه
انا اسمح لي قبل ما اسالك عن مواضيع تتعلق
بالفضاء وانت اسمك لامع ولديك كويكب حتى
في الفضاء باسمك اليوم انا حابه اعرف
دكتور فاروق الانسان كيف يعيش اجواء رمضان
طالما انت ظاهر معنا اليوم ولاول مره في
مسائل عربيه على شاشه العربيه بدون اجواء
رمضان المباركة كيف يعيش دكتور فاروق
اجواء رمضان ومن حوله من اصدقاء واهل كل
سنه وانت طيبه وكل سنه كلهم طيبين احنا
رمضان من ايام زمان قوي انا والدي كان
مدرس في الازهر الشريف فكان بالنسبه لنا
رمضان حاجه كبيره جدا واحنا من الصغار ما
زال عندك عند هذه الشعور بنحتفل برمضان
احتفال كبير جدا وبنسعد بيه خالص والحمد
لله انا بعرف الرسوم لان احنا سالته
تقدر تعمل اعمل ما يهمك الحمد لله
في رمضان زي ما الناس كلها بتهز طيب دكتور
كنت عام 1969
[موسيقى]